hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from the final round of the
title tuesday that was played a few days
ago
yeah it's another satori versus hikaru
nakamura
and it's quite an amazing game features
a great moment where
because going into the final round
nakamura was uh leading the tournament
by half a point so he only needs a draw
i guess the claim first place and of
course uh our protagonist
abdul satorov here uh is will not have
any of that so
yeah it's really a wonderful game do
check it out and if you remember
we've covered some of his games on the
channel uh
i believe the most famous one is that
from the 2019 world blitz championship
he played against magnus carls and if
you haven't seen it do check it out
will be the first link in the
description below also just a crazy game
so let's check this game out
so uh with the white pieces opens with
e4
uh with e5 knight to f3 knight to c6 and
bishop to b5 so going for the
rule opus we have knight to f6 hikaru
goes for the berlin defense
and now castles we have knight captures
on e4 so this is all been played many
many times
uh d4 and now knight to d6 attacking the
bishop here
so d captures on e5 with knight captures
and b5 white temporarily sacrifices the
bishop but not really
because now a4 and the knight is trapped
the knight has no squares all of these
squares are nicely
uh taken by the white's pieces uh so
here at knight b to d4
uh giving back the knight this way
knight captures on d4 and now
d5 and here we go into a very well known
line that
a lot of top grand masters use
constantly to just draw the games out
right out of the opening e captures on
d6 knight capture sunday for queen
captures and queen characters and here
we have queen to e for check queen to e6
24 and queen to d6 and here you could
just repeat like this and
then claim it's a draw by threefold
repetition however uh here on move 12
abductor
decides that he is not interested in
drawing this he plays queen to e3 with
chicken says
uh he's he's ready to fight so here uh
if you just continue following the the
white queen for example queen e6
then white could play something like
queen to g3 now put pressure on c7 also
it will be
hard to develop the bishop because the
g7 pawn is hanging
and maybe not something hikaru would be
interested in so instead
after queen to e3 check hikaru continues
to developing with bishop to e7
and now knight to c3 so is it just a
normal developing move with the knight
or
is it uh or does it pack some poison
well if you just castle here then maybe
this for example if castles knight b5
can be very annoying this is a tag this
is attacked
this is attacked twice so hikaru doesn't
want to deal with this he plays
c6 now takes away the b5 and d5 squares
from the white knight
and now knight to e4 so uh developing uh
further with tempo as the black queen is
now under attack and there are a few
games where queen to e6 was played but
here hikaru plays queen to g6 and it is
now as of move 15 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how abdul sator continues
this he plays knight
to c5 so another move with the knight
making it again a bit problematic for
black the castle
now of course the bishop is pin so you
can't capture and if you castle then uh
well it's just uh you you lose a piece
here
you can't really develop your light
square bishop because the b7 pawn is
hanging however that's exactly what you
should do here bishop to e6 is an
extremely sharp line and if white is
crazy enough to actually go for this
spawn
then you can just castle and now after
the knight retreats you can just play
bishop to d5 and here
uh for the price of only one pawn black
would have a really
awesome attacking game uh but okay
hikaru played a queen to d6 but now
uh he uh he grants uh abdul sator a very
important tempo he plays
rook to e1 now saying that there is no
threat of capturing the knight because
if you capture i can simply capture the
bishop is again pinned now by the rook
so here hikaru plays b6 chases away the
knight this way
and now again the knight moves with
tempo knight to the e4
attacking the queen and now queen the e6
is the move
hikaru should play he played queen to e5
but this is now
uh this is now just uh uh bad uh so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
this uh really awesome move that i'll do
a tour of played here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
it's
it's not an easy move to find especially
this is a blitz game this is a three
minute blitz game
so pretty crazy stuff here he played a5
and now again
he doesn't allow hikaru to castle
because if you castle now
for example castles we can just capture
here and the rooks are not connected you
cannot recapture here
it doesn't really matter what you play
white is already uh so
so uh so great in this game for example
if you play a5 then then white already
has a past pawn on b6 that's defended
you can play bishop d2 bishop c3
get this guy into the game it is just
going to be really great for white
so instead after a5 he carries just
played b captures on a5 saying okay well
so what if i just capture it i mean
what's the point of this but now comes
rook captures on a5 this was the point
and now you cannot capture the rook if
you capture the rook then you're getting
checkmated as the title suggests
knight's the d6 check king f8 or rather
doesn't matter where you go queen
captures king jet and queen captures or
queen to e8 will be also checkmate
so instead after rook captures an a5
hikaru goes back queen to c7
attacking the rook but not really we
already saw that that's not happening
uh and here abdul satorov goes rook to
g5
now again the rook cannot be captured as
the bishop cannot move here
i will just show a fun line since it's a
three-minute blizz game of course so
they cannot
find everything but i will just show it
as it's super fun uh rook the h5 and now
the point is uh
after black castles you have this very
nice queen to d3 the basically the
thread is sacrificed the knight with
knight f6 check and deliver checkmate
black would have to play something like
g6 and now we just sacrifice the rook
bishop to h6 and after this is captured
now queen c3
we threaten checkmate and after this is
blocked now we eliminate the rook for
example king captures we can eliminate
this here
uh and it's very very unlikely that
black will be able to survive this yes
black is up a piece but
uh that doesn't matter so this was in
the position however abdu satoru
played rook the g5 and it's also
extremely potent uh the problem is
hikaru can just castle here after
castles uh it's hard to say
what uh what white's plan here is
because now the rook is hanging
and it doesn't seem like you have all
that many attacking resources
but uh the uh to his i imagine joy
he car did not castle he carol played
king to f8 and
now now white has a completely crushing
idea so once again uh for the last time
i paused the video and to win the game
for abductor
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
always sacrificing something like
whatever you
basically in this position there is not
much you can sacrifice except this rook
so
i imagine that was pretty much uh pretty
much too easy for you guys but okay
uh for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show yeah and here you can't
capture it if you capture it
then queen and bishop are eyeing that h6
square we're just going to deliver check
after the king moves
now comes knight f6 check a beautiful
knight sacrifice bishop has to capture
and now rook to e8 will be
checkmate so again hikaru avoids this
checkmate plays h6 now the rook
helps with the defense of the h6 square
but now queen to d4
now threatening just to move the rook
wherever then pick up the rook on h8
so bishop to e6 not much you can do here
and
now rook the g6 just threatening queen
captures here with checkmate
and not much can be done here again you
could try moving the rook for example
rook h7
but then we just capture here captures
with check after this is captured we're
gonna capture back
and if the black king starts escaping we
don't care we just deliver check after
bishop f8
queen to b for now and now again we're
threatening a lot of uh
will uh impossible threats to defend and
if queen to e7 now we even have knight
f6
check queen captures an f6 rook captures
an f8 with check
king the d7 now for example rook
captures an a8 and black is
uh black has a bishop for two rooks
that's not uh you you don't even comment
on this
so after rook the g6 uh obviously rook
h7 doesn't do anything
rook to g8 is possible but again uh
really bad because now the h6 square
isn't even defended
after the king moves we eliminated the
rook now and after bishop f8 is just
complete massacre here
it doesn't really matter what you play
check and now after king d7 there's even
knight f
knight f6 checkmate since all of these
squares are covered here
so instead after this rook to g6 he car
just captured the rook there is nothing
better but now comes queen captures an
h8
and he was in this position on move 25
that hikaru nakamura resigned in the
game
and norbeca satoru wins the uh chess.com
tuesday titled arena so here you resign
uh because you lose simply too much
material and your position is just
bad uh for example king f7 uh we can
just play queen h7 check
kink the e8 now we can play knight f6
check uh we don't even have to go for
the rook now if bishop captures we can
just uh capture the queen here the queen
is undefended
and if you move the king then then we do
it uh queen h8
check these are covered now so you have
to block with the bishops
and once the bishop blocks then we just
play queen captures an f8 checkmate
so really an incredible game and
incredible to crush hikaru like
this in 25 moves uh in the final round
of any tournament
and what i find the the most amazing
about this game is
uh is basically the opening so after
this position was reached uh after
queen uh captures and e6 and the
they they did one round of checks
uh it's like uh it's like hikaru
uh was not ready for this and i i i
don't know maybe it would work
against many top gyms because top gems
use this line to just to draw games
um you know when they face an opponent
that's of equal strength and maybe
uh of equal standings in the tournament
then you will use this
line in the royal opus to draw the game
but here uh abdul satorov just
completely obliterated him and
it all it took was that uh that knight
the c3 move and that knight from c3
uh just uh you know uh started uh
with all of these threats with going
here going here
threats of going to b5 hikaru kept
defending this and in the end
uh you know it was just 25 moves and
it's over
so a really impressive game by notre
dame satoru hope you guys enjoyed that
and uh yeah
a lot of you guys suggested this but i
always stress do use hashtag suggestion
to suggest more games as it's
much much easier for me to find uh gems
like these when you do
so uh once again i hope you uh really
hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank eric tichenor uh
taylor jenkins world's fair development
jerry driver and apple soda for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
cheering up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day